und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja Hayali
schönen guten Abend wenn der
Parteivorstand der CDU in Berlin
zusammenkommt dann ist das wenn
überhaupt eine kleine Nachricht wert
außer in den Tagen zuvor ist etwas
Bemerkenswertes passiert und das ist es
nicht nur für viele Beobachter sondern
wichtiger auch für Daniel Günther dem
CDU-Ministerpräsidenten aus
Schleswig-Holstein zu dem Vorgang in
Thüringen also bei denen die CDU mit den
Stimmen von AFD und FDP einen Antrag
gegen die Minderheitsregierung
durchsetzen konnte fand er ja ziemlich
klare Worte ich bilde keine Mehrheiten
mit Extremisten und wenn ich darauf
angewiesen bin dann weiß ich in dem
Augenblick ich kann meine Hand nicht
dafür heben
allerdings so Parteichef Friedrich Merz
sei das ja eine einzelung fragen wir
nach bei Theo call aus unserem
Hauptstadtstudio schön und am Theo wie
war das denn heute bei dem Treffen war
da Daniel Günther quasi allein zu Haus
also die in der Spitze der Union
verbreitete Meinung ist es nicht dauernd
über den Umgang mit der AFD in einen
parteiintern aber öffentlichen Streit zu
geraten das arbeitet aktuell in gewisser
Weise zugunsten der von Friedrich Merz
vorgegebenen Linie aber Daniel Günther
ist mit nicht in einer Einzelmeinung in
der anschließenden Pressekonferenz wurde
heute zwar von breiter Zustimmung für
die Thüringer Linie gesprochen genauer
Angaben wie viele aus der Parteiführung
sich wie geäußert haben gab es aber
nicht
erstaunlicherweise hat sich meines
Erachtens Friedrich Merz mit der Aussage
über Günther als Einzelmeinung eine
unnötige Flanke geöffnet denn die Partei
ist in der Frage des Umgangs mit der AFD
gespalten und jetzt kann jeder der
wieder Daniel Günther denkt mit einer
öffentlichen Äußerung die März schon
Darstellung leicht torpedieren du hast
es gerade schon angesprochen es gab im
Anschluss eine Pressekonferenz auf der
sich auch der Generalsekretär dann noch
mal geäußert hat können wir da noch mal
kurz rein
die Beschlusslage ist klar es gibt einen
unvereinbarkeitsbeschluss
in dieser Partei gibt es nachweislich
Nazis
möchte ich gar nichts mit zu tun haben
Jungs auch wirtschaftspolitisch ist
immer interessant zu sehen dass man sich
freut wenn es schlechte Nachrichten gibt
ich möchte dass es Deutschland wieder
besser geht und dieser
unvereinbarkeitsbeschluss gilt sagt der
Generalsekretär der CDU also dieser
unvereinbarkeitsbeschluss ist aber dann
doch irgendwie ja Auslegungssache und
die Ortsverbände im Osten machen eh was
Sie wollen so klang es jedenfalls hier
gestern Abend in einem Beitrag im heute
journal den wir gesendet haben ja das
kann man wirklich sagen also Zitat eines
sächsischen Gemeinderats die ich noch im
Ohr habe wir haben null Brandmauer man
kennt sich man schätze ich trinkt abends
ein Bier zusammen und denkt bei
Brandmauer eher an die Grünen da sind
schlicht zwei Welten unter dem Dach
einer Partei und mit afd-umfragen in
vier Bundesländern bei jeweils über 30%
dürfte das Problem künftig nur noch
größer werden übrigens ist das bei der
FDP in Thüringen ganz ähnlich die segelt
nur aktuell im polit einen Windschatten
der Christdemokraten auch die Liberalen
haben bei der grundsteuerabsenkung ja
gemeinsam mit der AFD für eine Mehrheit
gesorgt die Bundes FDP hatte schon
vorher entschieden dem Landesverband
kein Geld aus dem bundesweiten
kampagnenfonds zahlen aber die Reaktion
der Thüringer Liberalen war dann dann
könne man ja jetzt das eigene Konzept zu
100% umsetzen also auch da steht der
Bundespartei Freude ins Haus sagt Theo
call aus unserem Hauptstadtstudio vielen
Dank für deine Einschätzung
ja und dann schauen wir doch jetzt
einfach auch mal in den Osten immerhin
wird dort im nächsten Jahr in drei
Bundesländern der Landtag gewählt
Brandenburg Thüringen und Sachsen und
den allen dreien allen dreien
Bundesländern liegt die AFD aktuell in
den Umfragen vorn damit ist auch klar
alle Parteien sind unter Druck
insbesondere aber die jeweiligen
Ministerpräsidenten wie jetzt regieren
wie reagieren welche Themen setzen
Cornelia schiemens berichtet aus Sachsen
wo der Countdown schon läuft
in Sachsen ist der Wahlkampf gestartet
zünftig mit Schweinesteak und Grillkäse
Staatsregierung im Gespräch so der Name
des Formats geladene Gäste
abgeschiedenes Hotel ohne störende
Zwischenrufer die gesellschaftliche
Spaltung beschäftigt hier jeden ich
schaue so ein bisschen mit Sorge auf die
Gesellschaft weil damals sind alles
Menschen und warum kann man nicht
miteinander warum kann man nicht
miteinander reden und auf der anderen
Seite merken wir das natürlich auch im
Alltag dass die AFD hier Menschen fängt
und dass sie Stimmung macht die
umfragezahlen die sprechen ja ist ja
eindeutig Sprache und davor habe ich
Angst jüngste Umfragen sehen die AFD in
Sachsen führend mit 35 Prozent der
Ministerpräsident will zwar eigentlich
keine Regierung mehr mit den Grünen aber
doch irgendwie weiter regieren Ziel ist
dass wir stärkste Kraft werden und
wieder eine Regierung aus der
gesellschaftlichen Mitte herausbilden
können das ist wichtig und deswegen ist
jetzt jeder Tag Arbeit ist ein ein
wichtiger seit Monaten knirscht es
heftig im Gebälk der selbst ernannten
arbeitskoalition kein Thema an diesem
Abend statt Verbalattacke Kuschelkurs es
geht um Vertrauen der Menschen das was
hinbekommen denn deswegen müssen wir
alles sehr aufpassen wie wir
übereinander reden weil dieses Vertrauen
das Fundament der Demokratie ist
beobachter fürchten einen polarisierten
Wahlkampf der sich hauptsächlich gegen
die Grünen richtet nicht gegen die AFD
von dieser Polarisierung die auch von
demokratischen Parteien mitgetragen wird
profitiert die AFD am stärksten und das
wird zu weitere Ohnmacht das wird tu
einem schmutzigen Wahlkampf zu einem
populistischen Wahlkampf führen den man
ja jetzt schon in sozusagen im Anfängen
beobachten muss wenn Sie Interesse haben
kontaktieren sie uns einfach hier sind
die Kontaktdaten alle drin René Bochmann
afd-bundestagsabgeordnete auf Werbetour
in Schkeuditz bei Leipzig Unterstützer
akquirieren Wähler mobilisieren
Stimmungen auf nehmen dafür steht er
hier sieben Stunden am Stück weil er
einen Traum hat
jeder Traum
ist eigentlich der Ursprung eines Ziels
und wenn wir weiter so machen und ich
glaube das wäre leistbar können wir
diese absolute Mehrheit erreichen Wähler
und Abgeordneter bestätigen sich
gegenseitig in ihren Meinungen gegen die
da oben in Dresden und in Berlin
persönlich habe ich eigentlich keine
Probleme bloß ich ich bin so also so
wütend auf diese scheiß Politik die hier
betrieben wird das Deutschland
eigentlich nur bergab geht
wirtschaftlich
nicht bezahlbarer Wohnraum für viele
Leute
es ist eigentlich alles in schief
nachher gekommen Arbeit muss ich lohnen
und was noch für ein Spruch nichts ist
eingetreten gar nichts das regt mich so
auf ich bin enttäuscht und wütend es ist
diese wachsende Wut die Politik und
Gesellschaft umtreiben und auf die
dringend eine Antwort gefunden werden
muss
und ein weiteres großes Thema nicht nur
in Zeiten des Wahlkampfes ist ja die
Migration wie steuern wie begrenzen wie
verteilen wie integrieren wie abschieben
fragen über Fragen die seit Jahren immer
wieder hitzig debattiert werden mit
versprechen garniert aber eine wirkliche
Verbesserung stellt sich dann irgendwie
nicht ein weder für die geflüchteten
noch für die aufnehmenden Länder
ausbaden dürfen das dann bei uns
insbesondere die Kommunen und die
ehrenamtlichen Helfer frustrieren ganz
klar und wenn dann auch noch Migranten
aus ein und demselben Land sich hier die
Köpfe einschlagen und OnTop Polizisten
angreifen dann hört das Verständnis bei
vielen auf so geschehen erneut geschehen
muss man ja sagen auf einer
Veranstaltung von Eritreern in Stuttgart
über die Nachwehen zwei Tage nach den
Ausschreitungen Sven klasse
was da passiert ist am Samstag in
Stuttgart wird auch heute noch nach
beschäftigt Ermittlungsbehörden löst
gesellschaftliche Debatten aus
Gewaltexzesse auf offener Straße massive
Angriffe auf Polizeibeamte
die Kollegen haben berichtet dass sie
plötzlich und unerwartet einen
Steinregen ausgesetzt waren
eine Kollegin hat von einer Wand von
Steinen gesprochen
auch mit Metallstangen und Holzlatten
mit Nägeln wird auf Polizeibeamte
eingeschlagen 31 Polizisten werden
verletzt
anfangs sind nur 20 Beamte vor Ort die
sollen eine Veranstaltung in einer Halle
Schützen von Unterstützern des
diktatorischen Regimes in Eritrea der
Protest draußen gegen diese
Veranstaltungen und gegen das brutale
Regime schlägt in Gewalt um was so nicht
zu erwarten gewesen sei
das sind Veranstaltungen die auch in der
Vergangenheit regelmäßig stattgefunden
haben und die im Wesentlichen völlig
störungsfrei verlaufen sind das mag für
Stuttgart Stimmen dennoch hätte man
gewarnt sein können Gießen Anfang Juli
auch hier kommt es zur Ausschreitungen
von Gegnern des eritreischen Regimes am
Rande einer Veranstaltung von
mutmaßlichen Unterstützern des
diktatorischen Präsidenten des Landes
die Erkenntnisse aus Gießen waren uns
bewusst sie waren aber auf diese
Veranstaltung am Samstag überhaupt nicht
anwendbar warum ist der Gewerkschaft der
Polizei unklar sie fordert auch die
Politik zum Handeln auf in der Tat wurde
seit Anfang Juli aus den Lehrern Gießen
keine solchen gezogen die Politik hat
sich mit warmen Worten sehr weit in
Deutschland medial bewegt aber unterm
Strich ist nichts passiert nach
Stuttgart drängt nun politisch erneut
die Frage wie umgehen mit Konflikten aus
anderen Ländern die auch in Deutschland
ausgetragen werden und mit
Tatverdächtigen aus diesen Ländern
das kann nicht sein dass diese Konflikte
aus dem Ausland hier bei uns ausgetragen
werden das müssen wir verhindern und
deswegen appelliere ich auch an
diejenigen die da Entscheidungen tragen
ob es in den Ordnungsämtern der Städte
ist doch zu prüfen ob man sowas nicht
unterbinden kann aber natürlich auch an
Gerichte die das Überprüfen einfach noch
mal hin zu gucken was es in Gießen
passiert was es jetzt wieder in
Stuttgart passiert Gewalt
ist kein Mittel der politischen
Auseinandersetzung
das muss jeder in diesem Land wissen die
Abschiebung von Täter nach Eritrea
allerdings auch aus Teilen der
baden-württembergischen CDU gefordert
dürfte schwierig werden unter anderem
wegen der dortigen Menschenrechtslage
aus dem ebenfalls CDU-geführten
Landesjustizministerium heißt es auf
zdf-anfrage Abschiebungen nach Eritrea
sein aktuell aus rechtlichen Gründen
nicht möglich
das Thema wird uns sicherlich weiter
beschäftigen und wir beginnen jetzt mit
den Nachrichten und Gundula mit einem
Thema was uns auch schon sehr lange
beschäftigt wir im Osten der Ukraine
wird weiterhin schwer gekämpft die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte meldeten nach
der Rückeroberung mehrerer Dörfer auch
den Durchbruch einer Verteidigungslinie
nahe bachmut unterdessen hat
Bundesverteidigungsminister Pistorius
weitere militärunterstützung für die
Ukraine angekündigt laut Bild-Zeitung
Munition im Volumen von 400 Millionen
Euro
vor dem Internationalen Gerichtshof hat
erstmals ein Vertreter Russlands
gesprochen er forderte die Klage der
Ukraine wegen der Invasion abzuweisen
und sprach von
verfahrensmissbrauch er erneuerte den
Vorwurf die Ukraine werde von Neonazis
regiert
ohne Angabe von Gründen hat das
ukrainische Kabinett sechs Vize
Verteidigungsminister entlassen darunter
die bekannte vizeministerin Hanna Mall
Jahr der neue Verteidigungsminister
omerov spricht von einem Neustart erst
Anfang September war sein Vorgänger
resnikow entlassen worden wegen
Korruptionsvorwürfen in seinem
Ministerium die eressnikow
zurückgewiesen hatte
Polen wird von einem möglichen
Korruptions Skandal bei der Vergabe von
Visa für Bürger aus Afrika und Asien
erschüttert
medienberichten zufolge sollen polnische
Beamte gegen Bezahlung hunderttausende
Visa für den Schengen Raum illegal
vergeben haben die rechtskonservative
Regierung die in der EU für eine harte
Linie in der Migrationspolitik steht
spricht von 200 Fällen
Oppositionsführer Tusk von 250.000
in Polen wird am 15 Oktober ein neues
Parlament gewählt mehr zu den Folgen der
Korruptionsvorwürfe im heute journal
Update um 0020
die Erzfeinde USA und Iran haben einen
über Monate eingefädelten
Gefangenenaustausch durchgeführt fünf im
Iran inhaftierte US-Bürger kamen dabei
frei sie sind mittlerweile in Katar
gelandet das Golf Emirat war an den
Verhandlungen beteiligt im Gegenzug
entlassen die USA fünf iranische
Häftlinge außerdem sollte heran auf
eingefrorene Gelder in Höhe von
umgerechnet fünfeinhalb Milliarden Euro
zugreifen können
aus Protest gegen eine Äußerung von
bundesaußenministerin beerburg hat das
chinesische Außenministerium die
deutsche Botschafterin eingestellt
während ihrer USA Reise hatte bärburg
vergangene Woche in einem Interview
Chinas Präsidenten Ski als Diktator
bezeichnet Peking sieht darin eine
schwere Verletzung der politischen würde
Chinas und eine offene politische
Provokation
vor der morgen beginnenden
UN-Vollversammlung in New York
bilanzieren die Staats- und
Regierungschefs auf einem
nachhaltigkeitsgipfel der Vereinten
Nationen die bisherigen Bemühungen im
Kampf gegen Armut
Bundeskanzler Scholz kritisierte dabei
weltweite Versäumnisse und forderte
Fortschritte für ein besseres
Zusammenleben
un-generalsekretärisch legte einen so
wörtlich Rettungsplan für die Menschheit
und den Planeten vor den unzufolge sind
nur 15% aller Vorsätze auf Kurs
nur bei 15% liegt man im vorgesehenen
Zeitplan das ist echt mickrig hinzu
kommt dass es in einigen Bereichen nicht
nur keinen Fortschritt sondern sogar
Rückschritte gibt das kann selbst die
UNO nicht mehr schön reden dabei war 20
15 in dem Jahr also als die 17 sozialen
wirtschaftlichen und ökologischen Ziele
festgelegt wurden die Euphorie und die
Hoffnung groß dass diese Ziele wirklich
erreicht werden könnten immerhin geht es
um nichts Geringeres als um die Existenz
zahlreicher Menschen weltweit immer
teven ist für uns in New York dabei
immer sind diese Ziele wirklich bis 2030
nicht mehr zu erreichen oder doch noch
also es wird extrem schwer werden aber
man hat hier ja diesen Rettungsplan
wirklich verabschiedet einstimmig
übrigens und der enthält viele konkrete
Punkte die man einfach im Jahr 2015
vergessen hat indem man nämlich jetzt
Strukturen schafft und schaffen wird die
dafür sorgen dass Länder in der Lage
sind diese Ziele zu erreichen ein
Beispiel es soll einfacher werden
Kredite zu bekommen über Weltbank und
Währungsfonds es wird einfacher
Privatinvestoren zu finden die eben in
Großprojekte investieren und wenn man so
etwas macht wie beispielsweise in Ausbau
des Stromnetzes in Afrika soll mit
berücksichtigt werden dass man dabei auf
erneuerbare Energien setzt das kann man
schaffen wenn man Technologien und Geld
bekommt das spielt Deutschland eine ganz
wichtige und große Rolle und insofern
kann man glaube ich sagen so konkret wie
es jetzt in der Erklärung steht war es
eigentlich noch nie ob das zu schaffen
ist das liegt an den Politikern das
hätte man sich dann vielleicht auch
früher überlegen können aber du hast
gerade Deutschland angesprochen einen
kleinen Grund zum Feiern gibt es ja
heute dennoch jedenfalls aus deutscher
Sicht denn heute vor 50 Jahren da traten
die BRD und die DDR der UNO bei sie
wurden damals Mitglieder Nummer 133 und
134 und auch wenn die Bilder wie Sie
sehen damals schon bunt waren so wurde
die Welt damals politisch politisch
schon noch in Schwarz und Weiß geteilt
also konkret in Ost und West Elmar und
durch den Angriffskrieg der Russen hat
man ja fast das Gefühl die Uhr dreht
sich wieder so ein bisschen zurück
welche Rolle spielt das Thema heute
ja heute eine riesige Rolle wenn man das
Gefühl hat dieser Angriffskrieg bremst
eben auch die Erfüllung dieser
Nachhaltigkeitsziele Willy Brandt hat
1973 übrigens interessanterweise gesagt
wenn es der Welt nicht gelingt die
Gewalt zurückzudrängen und zu echten wie
soll sie dann die friedensprobleme
eigentlich lösen können und genau das
gilt hier in den nächsten Tagen ist
deshalb Ukraine das riesige Thema morgen
bei der Generalversammlung am Mittwoch
im Weltsicherheitsrat und wir rechnen
damit dass es eben auch neue
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine geben
soll und das Russland hier eigentlich
isolierter ist als es das in den letzten
ein zwei Jahren war eben weil man das
Gefühl hat dieser Krieg steht der
Erreichung der Nachhaltigkeitsziele im
Weg und deswegen ist die Chance größer
denn je dass man auch in Sachen wo
keiner ein Stück weit voran kommt sagt
aus New York vielen Dank
und wir haben es gerade ja auch schon
gesehen auch der Bundeskanzler also Olaf
Scholz ist in New York wird aber
wahrscheinlich dennoch verfolgen was ich
gerade in Bonn abspielt immerhin taucht
sein Name in der Anklageschrift 27 Mal
auf ja es geht um cumex mal wieder aber
dieser Prozess könnte Olaf Scholz auf
die Füße fallen denn auf der Anklagebank
sitzt Christian olearius früherer Chef
der warburgbank das ist die Bank an die
die Hamburger Finanzverwaltung
Steuerforderungen in Millionenhöhe hatte
diese dann aber doch verjähren ließ
kritiker sagen verjähren liest nachdem
sich oliarius mit dem Ersten
Bürgermeister traf Scholz sie erinnern
sich erinnert sich zwar an die Treffen
nicht aber an deren Inhalt vom ersten
Prozesstag Christoph Schneider
während die Staatsanwaltschaft schon
fast eine halbe Stunde vor
Prozessauftakt präsent ist betritt der
81-Jährige Angeklagte Christian olearius
eingerahmt von vier Verteidigern erst
kurz vor zehn den Sitzungssaal kaum eine
Erregung nur gelegentlich ein Schmunzeln
so zeigt sich der ehemalige top Banker
vor dem Landgericht die Zuschauerreihen
gut gefüllt einer von ihnen Fabio de
Marzi bei schon manchen Strafverfahren
rund um cum ex-geschäfte hat dieser
Prozess eine besonders herausgehobene
Stellung findet der ehemalige linken
Abgeordnete und Finanzexperte die
Verfahren hat eine enorme Bedeutung auch
eine hohe symbolische Bedeutung weil es
jetzt wirklich um die obersten Etagen
geht also um den ehemaligen
Gesellschafter der war durch Bank und
nicht irgendeinen kleinen Angestellten
und das sendet natürlich enorme
Schockwellen auch durch die durch die
Vorstände von Banken die sich an solchen
kriminellen Geschäften beteiligt haben
und deswegen ist das sehr sehr wichtig
Überstunden zeichnet die
Staatsanwaltschaft in ihrer Anklage ein
detailliertes Bild eines abgestimmten
Systems bei dem allen Beteiligten
bewusst gewesen sei dass die Profite der
cum-ex-geschäfte gerade durch
unzulässige Steuertricks entstehen
olearius soll die verbotenen Geschäfte
nicht nur abgesegnet sondern auch
initiiert haben Angeklagte soll bei 13
Fällen in den veranlagungsjahren 2007
bis 2011 als Hauptanteilseigner als
persönlich haftender Gesellschafter und
Sprecher der Partner eine Hamburger
Privatbank sogenannte illegale
cum-ex-geschäfte begangen haben das
Prinzip cumex Banken Aktienhändler und
steueranwälte schoben sich trickreich
Aktien Pakete hin und her so dass das
Finanzamt nicht mehr folgen konnte dabei
wurde die fällige Steuer nur einmal
bezahlt am Ende vom Finanzamt aber
mehrfach zurückerstattet Schaden für den
Fiskus insgesamt geschätzt mehr als 10
Milliarden Euro im Fall von oliarius
geht es um knapp 280 Millionen Euro und
auch der Name des Bundeskanzlers spielt
eine Rolle
da kommt 27 Mal in der Anklageschrift
vor er hat sich drei Mal mit Herrn
olearis getroffen als gegen den bereits
ermittelt wurde es bereits eine razziale
Bank gab um mit ihm über das laufende
Steuerverfahren zu diskutieren auf der
Zeugenliste des Landgerichts steht Olaf
Scholz bisher nicht übermorgen wird
olearius Verteidigung Stellung zur
Anklage nehmen und für Mitte Oktober hat
die 13 Strafkammer die ersten Zeugen
vorgesehen insgesamt sind 28
Verhandlungstage bis Ende März kommenden
Jahres bestimmt vorerst
und mit Nachrichten aus der Wirtschaft
machen wir jetzt weiter und da schauen
wir wieder mal Gundula auf den
Wohnungsmarkt ja es werden immer weniger
Baugenehmigungen erteilt laut
Statistischen Bundesamt wurde im Juli
der Bau von nur
21.000 Wohnungen genehmigt fast ein
Drittel weniger als im Vorjahresmonat
die Krise verschärft sich Frank Bethmann
die Bundesregierung plante den Bau von
400.000 neuen Wohnungen pro Jahr was
bleibt davon übrig tja es wird immer
schwieriger in den ersten sieben Monaten
des Jahres wurden noch nicht einmal
160.000 Wohnungen genehmigt die
bundesbahnministerin hat längst
eingeräumt dass das Ziel in diesem Jahr
deutlich verfehlt werde um 20% höhere
Baukosten dazu Zinsen die sich
mittlerweile vervierfacht haben und
möglicherweise sogar noch weiter steigen
werden schließlich hat die Europäische
Zentralbank den Leitzins erst die jüngst
weiter angehoben die Erhöhung der Zinsen
wird Rezession am Bau weiter anheizen
prophezeit der Hauptgeschäftsführer des
Hauptverbandes der Deutschen
Bauindustrie die Branche befindet sich
im freien Fall für nächsten Montag ist
ein wohnungsgipfel im Kanzleramt
angesetzt wie können da neue Weichen
gestellt werden die Immobilienbranche
verbindet mit dem Gipfel große
Hoffnungen bauen muss billiger werden
günstigere Hypothekenkredite für
Bauherren staatlich gefördert während
hilfreich weiterhin fordert der
Bausektor die Absenkung der
Grunderwerbsteuer weniger Bürokratie
hier vor allem eine schnellere
Bearbeitung der Bauanträge sowie eine
vergünstigte Abgabe öffentlicher
Grundstücke für den Mietwohnungsmarkt
viel Holz für einen zweistündigen Gipfel
bei dem rund 40 Vertreter der
unterschiedlichen Interessengruppen mit
am Tisch sitzen werden und wir werden
berichten von Bethmann vielen Dank
eingängige Balladen und mitreißende
Schlager waren das Markenzeichen von
Roger Whittaker die heute bekannt wurde
ist der britische Sänger und
Liedermacher vergangene Woche im Alter
von 87 Jahren in Südfrankreich gestorben
erste große Erfolge feierte Roger
Whittaker mit englischen oder auch
gepfiffenen Titeln
zum gefeierten Star hierzulande wurde
Whittaker in den 1970er und 80er Jahren
mit deutschsprachigen Liedern auch durch
viele Auftritte in der ZDF Hitparade
[Musik]
wer einmal einen Schirach in der Hand
hatte der legt ihn nicht so schnell
wieder weg so erging es jedenfalls sehr
vielen die damals sein erstes Buch
lassen Verbrechen gefolgt von Schuld in
den beiden dünnen kleinen aber gewaltig
feinen Bänden erzählte Schirach von
echten Fällen aus seiner Zeit als
Strafverteidiger in Berlin mit seinem
neuesten Werk knapp 50 Seiten Erzählung
plus 50 seinen Interview schafft er
erneut etwas Besonderes und erneut auch
den Sprung in die Bucht Schatz über eine
Liebeserklärung Anschreiben
es regnet ein einsamer Mann betritt die
Bahn er setzt sich bestellt einen Trink
genauso beginnt der neue Schirach
mögen sie regen ich bin klatschnass ich
stand 20 Minuten draußen
da drüben vor dem blauen Haus
eine Premiere Schirach steht solo auf
der Bühne der Bestseller Autor trägt
sein neues Buch selbst vor der nächste
Schritt Schirach als Schauspieler so
geht er bald auf Tournee yes Kostproben
wissen Sie ob man hier rauchen darf
ja danke
in Berlin darf man noch im Restaurant
Rauchen also nicht offiziell natürlich
offiziell ist das längst verboten wie
überall aber
abends um 11 Uhr nachdem alle gegessen
haben stellt man ihnen
eine
Untertasse auf den Tisch Aschenbecher
ist als wenn die Anti raucherfraktion
das wüsste die würde durchdrehen
Schirach spielt sich selbst und Wagnis
oder gar Größen waren
mir macht es einfach große Freude das zu
machen und zu spielen und wir haben ja
alle nur ein sehr begrenztes Leben und
es ist wenn wir uns umdrehen schon
vorbei
Ferdinand von Schirach Wasser anfasst
wird zu Gold über 10 Millionen verkaufte
Bücher in 40 Ländern es schreibt über
Menschen im Alltag über Menschen am
Abgrund Niederlagen muss man erleben
sonst funktioniert es nicht also wenn
sie wenn sie nichts haben
was sie erschüttert gibt es die dann
schreiben Sie über Blumenwiesen ja und
es ist zwar ganz hübsch über
Blumenwiesen aber das ist wie wie
hotelkunst ja oder oder oder
aufzugs-musik oder sowas das bedeutet
nicht Schirach probt seine
Bühnenpremiere auf Schloss Ellmau
schöner geht es kaum als in der
bayerischen alpenisse doch der
59-Jährige macht sich Sorgen ums Land
sein Großvater war die Nazi Größe Baldur
von Schirach der Enkel warnt nun davor
die Gefahr eines afd-ausstieges zu
unterschätzen wenn wir diese Partei in
irgendeiner Form in die
Regierungsverantwortung bekommen dann
ist das Land verloren das ist überhaupt
keine Frage und da können wir auch keine
Späße drüber machen das ist wirklich
ernst
Schirach will wachutteln sein Leitmotiv
die Würde des Menschen und Wachsamkeit
vor Diktatur und Willkür eigentlich bin
ich Schriftsteller müssen Sie wissen
es ist ein sehr langweiliger Beruf
offenbart zu langweilig für ihn nach dem
Juristen Schriftsteller nun also der
Schauspieler Schirach sein
bemerkenswerter Weg zeigt einmischen
lohnt sich
und er hat mal gesagt manchmal verlieren
wir uns und die Dinge gehen schief ich
hoffe dass wir uns heute nicht verloren
haben und eins ist sicher Nazan guckte
mir wird sich später um 0:20 Uhr mit
unserem Update melden das war's von uns
beiden machen sie es gut wo auch immer
sie sind tschüss bis morgen
[Musik]
schon guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ja die erste
Septemberhälfte war ja deutlich zu warm
und eine richtig herbstliche Wetterlage
stellt sich erst einmal nicht ein auch
wenn es jetzt deutlich durchwachsener
wird mit Schauern und Gewittern zum
Beispiel in der Nacht im Südwesten das
wird durchaus hier sehr ungemütlich
teils mit Starkregen werden und das
ganze verlagert sich ostwärts ja und
morgen da lockert es auf und die Sonne
kommt hervor und es wird nach und nach
Trockner schauen wir uns die Nacht an im
Detail hier im Südwesten gibt also
kräftige schon Gewitter teils mit
starkregendes verlagert sich ostwärts
auch im Osten gibt es Schauer und dazu
Blitz und Donner und das bei tiefsten
Temperaturen von 9 Grad hier im
hessischen Bergland deutlich mildern
Oder und Neiße mit 16 bis 17 Grad und
morgen im Südosten noch letzte Schauer
die sich allmählich südostwärts
verabschieden ganz im Nordwesten kommen
neue Schauer auf und das mit einem
relativ kräftigen Wind aus Südwest teils
mit Sturmböen dort und das bei höchsten
Temperaturen von 24 Grad ganz im Osten
Deutschlands und auch im Südwesten 18
Grad zum Beispiel an der Nordsee ja der
Mittwoch ist komplett trocken und
ziemlich warm mit Temperaturen bis 27
Grad Donnerstag sogar bis 29 Grad aber
dann kommen Schauer und Gewitter von
Westen her auf Freitag ist es nicht ganz
so warm aber für September immer noch
ziemlich mild damit ein schönen Abend